un thriller iraní y un drama francés
fueron los protagonistas de la noche en
cannes
[Música]
no está
mal
[Música]
la nada
el jurado en cannes examinó la cinta
hole y spider del iraní ali abbas y una
película inspirada en hechos reales
sobre un asesino en serie en los años
[Música]
los hechos se desarrollan en la ciudad
santa de mayada donde aparecen muertas
varias prostitutas estranguladas por un
hombre que dice querer limpiar la ciudad
del vicio una joven periodista decide
investigar estos hechos
teniéndose que enfrentar a los jueces la
policía y las autoridades religiosas
holly spider es una dura denuncia de la
condición de las mujeres en irán donde
conviven patriarcado dominación
religiosa y misoginia
la ítalo-francesa valeria bruni tedeschi
presentó en la competencia de cannes les
damos un 10 una vocación de una escuela
en un célebre teatro que dirigió un
monumento de las artes escénicas patrice
chéreau
añade
es una cinta fresca sobre muchachos que
aspiraban a convertirse en actores en un
momento donde reinaban drogas sexo el
miedo por el sida pero sobre todo el
fervor por el teatro en tu mundo
llevarla